in less than two weeks we'll be free of
all mandatory covert restrictions
but the virus will also be unbridled
free to run wild
so what happens next well cases are now
averaging
over 26 000 a day by july the 19th the
prime minister has said they'll have
doubled
to 50 000 and the health secretary has
said they could reach
100 000 a day later in the summer
so is the government right to give up on
the controls well let's
look at some of them nightclubs will be
free to open from july the 19th
one study estimated that keeping them
closed reduced the r number the rate at
which the virus spreads
by 12 reopening the doors could lead to
super spreader events social distancing
has also been effective
staying at least one meter apart from
someone with covet
reduces the chance of infection from 13
to just three percent so crowding
together again
increases the risk what about masks now
hotly debated of course
researchers estimate from studies around
the world that if the entire population
of a country
wears them the r number is reduced by 26
but they also found that national
mandates corresponded with only an
eight percent increase in the number of
people who said they'd wear a mask all
or most of the time
so many people may now choose to
continue wearing masks in certain
situations
even though they don't have to but all
these studies were done
before widespread vaccination so the
controls
might be less effective now as immunity
rises
and fear of the virus falls it seems the
government has gambled
everything on the effectiveness of the
vaccine right now the data is in its
favor
back in january one in every 50 cases
resulted in someone dying
now it's fewer than one in a thousand
but if
daily cases do reach 100 000
even that very small risk can still add
up
to 100 extra deaths a day
the delta variant will sweep the globe
so
other countries are looking at how we
are dealing with them
at the same time as reopening the
economy in a sense
it is an experiment and we are the
guinea pigs